were so full podcast was so full podcast
I'm right here Felipe Esparza which was
real Torres the host of the year now we
have the cocoa host of the year every
Weaver eyes here are the way you know he
just let the kids with a 90-inch it blow
it up like the six-man here [ __ ] it at
the table all talking about when I first
started I started with its comical at
the natural budge and we have Brian
Holtzman here and he talked about it and
we also had a al Berman here he talked
about it and we also had Jamie Kennedy
bro yeah and you know the people that I
started with at this place where they
will sell vegan food even though vegan
food the owner of long hey don't forget
to try to pocket that burger
are you comment don't forget to pay
three dollars so yeah maybe a rubric
Abdallah man originally from the valley
right Valley yeah we won eight weight
from originated from right there howling
back max by Hollenbeck Park easterly
then Bruno she got all crazy and my mom
moved us all out to a Santa face free we
are big initiatives are from two or
three and three two three eight one
eight nine five one nine oh nine dogs
everyone four five area coda and also we
have people Colorado also anybody who
moved from LA who lives somewhere else
listen to his podcast all the way to in
Japan we have a guy who translates this
[ __ ] into Japanese alright and we have a
guy named Glenn Carling in Ireland was
so full he watches on YouTube and us
warrior in Australia I was worried
Australia why do you have what's up fool
t-shirts and Japanese if you said you'll
grow my cut
[Laughter]
what's up fool man it was very
hurry beer man last time we saw you we
were father about Elka Chicano right
yeah I went to go see I went to go
support that we made up seven hundred
and eighty thousand dollars in six
hundred theaters so it was like if you
when I want to look it up it'll actually
talk to a movie
oh yeah I want to listen to be a great
movie that [ __ ] like if you spent 30
million to make your movie and and
Chicano is above you you should start
making feels right I started
documentaries
yeah measure that's a guy somebody call
it Chicano and I probably played in
Visalia where you're from now anybody
was no poverty when you grew up so Mike
yes
you broke though originally born right
yeah vodkas like that my stepson
actually so he graduated from Pacoima oh
really
what school for clear with your high
school city that's my dumb street right
outside what's in Pacoima we're gonna be
a bird bags Rick it doesn't matter he's
like a Christian now but I fooled the
animal back in the day when I when I
first met this guy like I was going to
this place called natural fudge and I
will see that the Mooney twins there man
and I would see like Brian Holtzman he
was to close it out could nobody can
follow him because the owner will get
manager and just total [ __ ] off don't
work comedy today no better her so hard
you know there was your [ __ ] fat ass
[ __ ]
like really like hard cool right yeah
like honey got a flat iron your flat
titties and then you have to go up so
they would have a comedian go up and
they were here while you're performing
some young punk group was purport was
setting up behind you so then they were
plate a set and then when they're
getting off a comedian is up there so it
was like shitty rock band and then like
a little those people there man they
woke up that morning and you want to do
comedy and what you natural fudge it and
then you do the the midnight show until
like 2:00 in the morning I never work
for the Prudential no I
they were private either got it or body
so what a lot of boulders there and then
let their post or subdivisions over
there like Rita Rudner there's all these
carbons right the way is think I'm you
update and then I ask allows the boric I
don't know who was who right I would
view and I through all these people
against the Stars but our but this food
these two fools walked in their bra and
killed their bro like nobody else was
funny bro like they were funny but not
like professionally where they were
getting laugh back to back
that's our rubric is done I came in the
real the [ __ ] long a pony looking
like a big big-ass bow [ __ ] you Johnny
Redcorn and I felt good it when he
showed up because I wouldn't know how to
dress you know that to be a comedian
I think it was just a certain way so I
just had like a coat like Fozzie Bear
posse girl
yeah Fozzie Bear like a coat and I had a
bolo brought a tie what do they put a
bit okay man bowls are in yeah the
comedian succumbs 80s out Harry show who
keep me the Brooke killing it bro like
blowing it up and I was dying
you've always gave this full problem
everything will relatable to me bro the
[ __ ] Bob with [ __ ] a Bob Batman
Ruben no man able to spray-paint single
Cass faster than a drive-by shooting
powerful than a chorizo burrito just
look for the lowrider in the sky yeah
that was cool but back to a dog like no
one no one else you know there's Paul
Rodriguez columnist here but Italy were
usually I saved Tommy Davidson
yeah bro tell us cuz we were at at we
were at
wasn't even a place that you know the le
cabaret yeah and Tommy Davidson he was
the MC right in this one Texas dude big
all talked out boy he wouldn't get off
the stage and Tommy was given him the
like giving him the like if in the line
he got up there and he told the guy to
get off and the guy reached over and was
gonna attack Tommy and I saw that from
the from the bar the screen right so I
ran up then I still had my Pendleton all
buttoned up to the top and everything in
with my bandana on and I do down yeah
the for up a data bro Salazar I tackled
a man got him off the stage in their
time you know penalty Kate bro had a
penalty so what do you guys start man
yeah though how do I beat each other
because my other knows well my other
from Sherman and he's got a podcast to
his dad was our karate instructor right
so so every time he would come over and
I would do something bad she'll blame it
on the fact that I'm hanging out with a
black dude she didn't speak English
machine you the the slurs right the
racial slurs right so hey bye-bye yeah
he said right I cou what they have boy
what bowls a right like like no their
bones here some pork ish that's a flat
thought and it was look good Ruben said
we'll be careful with it I said whatever
man so I think they like and I was
dipping the tip in the 7-zip in and he
got right there my token grab me
children
yeah oh yeah yeah home savings it was a
badass building then a big one in
Hollywood yeah yeah but don't so sir
with marble and statues and all kinds I
will supply all the all everything for
the all united states of yeah
check everything check whatever you see
man pens papers laptops laptops back
there we shipped it out to everybody
yeah I was doing saying I was doing
comedy was I had a partner at the time
the comedy team of Byron and Charles way
back yeah Byron Charles fired and
Charles and then after that what kind of
cover the guys do Negro comedy who was a
straight man Oh Charles would he was a
he was the perfect straight man he would
and set it up and then I would coming in
knocking down with the punch the funny
thing is when we broke up I was just
used to do watch ha ha ha how hard is it
to have a duel we will be grew up
together so it was easier that's all we
to do like when we hang out at the club
or whatever
we just are riffs but we need me think
of it would just be a natural
I didn't we talked about we did radio
radio took us to stage and then why'd
you guys break up yeah well no we uh
well that year we were slamming it we
were crushing it and then when a year
ran out
our material ran out we have to have a
hard time all the tournaments oh yeah
you know your bottle you will ba ba ba
ba we couldn't figure it out
and I'm said well let's go to the comedy
stores and this just worked I didn't
read forgotten he was like nah man once
the killing stopped he was out yeah I
can't no no hard we were we were at the
Berlin Robin here
yeah we were out there and we did so bad
could Robin Harris used to bag on
everybody
no he was so bad he didn't bag on a long
walk we always out to walk a shade room
it was yeah don't go to the bathroom in
that room no all the way down this room
over the black room Eric it was called a
comedy act theater a lot of Beatty comic
reviews were taped there and audition
there no early days yeah but across the
street with some bar a barbecue yeah
well but you don't know where to say it
was just two windows Hey and get your
food get out what yeah what do I eat
where do I sit down at those turn around
see whatever you want use your the broad
bag yeah stupid formula - yeah yeah I
remember what time we were was off of
Crenshaw right and ordered 13 Crenshaw
we were driving up there and some do
crawled out of the manhole it was an
Edward Turner behind us in the lunchroom
and it was me and Darren's do remember
Daris do over South Central right
Nickerson gardens that's where he's like
and and Byron used to sit behind us and
and listen to everything that we said
and then he'd go and bag on people yeah
I would I would write it down because
you wouldn't use it that time
so now we'll give him you know given the
premise as a real story and let him come
up with the punchline
a man so what we do Doug you then I
approach them I said it made you pretty
funny dude because he was bagging on
somebody really hard Tomo nice to do you
shoot the most a Joe but yeah by and say
hey watch it god come on on do an open
mic i ain't got didn't open my gran and
everybody in the warehouse like i
chicken jack and again I'm gonna do it
while I was corona synonym alright well
was the first place that the a leak
every yeah Ivan turbo yeah yeah I'm Bob
or yeah I would do that though I went to
the Bob or theater when it was a conical
comedy cabaret I would do during when it
was done cuz I looked through the photos
and it was happening at what time oh
yeah yeah what it was you know we got
going doing those Pat yeah yeah yeah cuz
I would I went there was like dad owners
soda I believe because he wanted to run
for City Council or something cuz they
were really taxed him on zoning nothing
like that and then he lost so after that
it's really spiraled after that so who's
the worst when you go to a club and it's
not the tail end but your pictures of
the girl that a good old day like David
said with us tape with that but it was
good it was good kind of like I was like
you know the comedy store has too many
rooms but you know it's kind of like
imagine the the bar and what's what room
do you like the best over the Congress
performance you're like the original
domain which one do you like belly the
belly belly Rubio yes okay so imagine
the Bali room and just a bar and people
and that's it's a perfect combination
yeah it was good and bad you see the
right yeah yeah yeah but then the second
owner came with each other at carbon
right into the bar on the outside I've
roomed two rooms and then the area block
Chris Chuck who came here one day and
trying to go up he didn't know who he
was
it turned him away and he was a really
famous oh yeah
but I go you are booking bands dog how
can you go from music to comedy man
especially if you don't know what's up
he didn't wanna listen to the young
comics you're like Ralph emails telling
you what's up
he kept telling him put my boy up and I
was telling writing from him he did it
put me while I was driving home sad
Ralphie me oh that's the worst I will
it'll put you up huh yeah never happen
to you all the time like we did you
start meeting when you were the first
show go for you the first show went
great I mean I guess for any first joke
first joke I remember I had to do but
pride growing up in East Los you know
try growing up or in jail that's me go
to me I went to a Santa Fe High School
holla back
no junior high was that Lake sinner so
my mother pulled us out you know crazy
huh yeah so I'd only said I don't
remember my first joke had it had to be
about date and had to be about dating
Mexican girls or something you know you
know that's how we all start right yeah
with all those types of jokes are
Mexican mamas and I don't remember any
of it I just remember the laughs the
tomorrow yeah the message Oh Felipe I
love that Joseph this was do a bit of
other go bro yes see ya we're so poor
and half GI Joe yeah we didn't have GI
Joe go with the Ballet's yeah yeah I
should make the balance shape little
Jojo
we used to have the hand-me-downs we
used to make our presents we didn't get
GI Joes we got my mother one time she
gave me a GI Joe made out of a tamale
she called a masa job so now when did
vato Batman show up that started when we
started doing the Laugh Factory
yeah when Jaime Jaime thought that you
know he would join in on the the wave Oh
Def Jam yeah it have a lot to do because
they had a better a waiver for black
comedians and then the Latino wave came
in what 1992 ish or 94 for yeah and a
lot of people think that that's that
that way started off with us but nom and
that all started back in a day was like
Freddie Prinze and it's their Cheech and
Rodriguez yeah before George came out
you know disrespected or anything like
that but you know that's when that
happened and then George kind of like
how the line for a while and then that's
when we came in
that's what we came in and started
blowing it up man everywhere and then
then you had to pick your spot you know
or your spot picked you like The Improv
you couldn't do
laughs actor you can Comedy Store you
know same thing with the other ones I
always wanted my name on that Comedy
Store wall to it Peter Chan just got it
up there he just posted a little while
ago that he got his name up there been
up there bro it's been up there they get
put reposted it back okay you know was
golden is here
oh the German chick yeah yeah yeah well
I say it's a night you dress up like wow
the man split a can of spray paint but
yeah when they pop the man show what
about the man showed up as a character
cuz Byron said you got two characters
man all right you got two characters all
right so I thought oh she's gonna up
there's a cholo superhero it was cool
and then like you know hey let's make a
cartoon character out of let's do some
animation out of it and but yeah I've
even had a lot of characters in his life
and he when he was like ecotripping more
money more money mack daddy and it was
based off of his preacher and he didn't
want to use it for this huh we had a
skit a sketch called we had a kung fu
sketch we joined this improv group man
and a great improv group the alley
no flip side the flip side of alley or
the flip side yeah and all these dudes
were talented man but me and Barbara the
only ones I came in there with with the
ghetto scrimp Rob's always bland is
[ __ ] yeah they was clear they didn't
like our skit but we write up a pistol
we had a caller caller so kvt okay motto
where you would get all the advice from
a cholo right you know as to what you
should do about your dates and stuff
like that and some guy calls up he's
part of the cast is on a [ __ ] you
speak why'd you go back to where you
came from poor day I'll shoot you from
your local when I pulled out the gun
right and then Barnes I'll come down
come down all right so I gave it another
one what time we're doing improv he got
me we're doing improv and I thought
everybody in the world seen 12 monkeys
I never seen he never seen I don't know
that everybody okay wrap it right yeah
so it's part of the skin I start doing
12 monkeys 12 monkeys Ruben took a step
back look at me right Latino night you
know host band a night Frazier
no no boomer bro yes from power 106 yeah
yes you know told me they were doing a
Spanish show the lady from the comedy
act [ __ ] now natural punch she told
her they were gonna do like Spanish
company back then yeah but but maybe
were Latino that would have a Spanish I
saw the world speaks yeah yeah so they
went to Johnny Sanchez told me right
right Johnny good we had him here too oh
really
laugh actor thing was pretty much
brought up by a Boomer you know he did
all the radio work for it and he was the
emcee and stuff like that and and I
think he was in charge of the lineup too
so that was a golden opportunity for a
lot of us man it was path doc yeah and
it's Jeanie you know if it wasn't for
Jamie I don't think there'd be a lot of
us out there that that
get that push that we needed you know it
started a little tiny Latino tonight at
The Comedy Store in a banner over some
old Latino comics yeah from The Comedy
Store forgot it mean at Puerto Rican he
they even around anymore but that guy my
diary
no just forgot it Frankie Frankie what
got a scale no no no is he still wrong
no he moved back to New York okay
all right you know right into fragments
on oh yeah I remember him he was there
when we did the taping for micro blurs
up in uh in New York for the fool do it
when I was [ __ ] now talking about this
bro I was that host Mike Robles the
Roger pod they hit me up right I don't
know how they hit me up but I'm by the
way man me and Gabriel s yes we booked
all the kilo cause if everybody wants to
know when the one that told I Roger Paul
the names were the one that told to poke
Dom Barrera we're the one that so it was
gay bro and I bro he's the one that put
that show everybody wants to know and by
the way we were that were that we didn't
book it but we give Mike Robles an
earful of here to put up and we never do
to our right the later one a local
comedy joke man is no Mike Robert did he
just flipped the coin and he [ __ ] I
told you to pick his head or tail rose
to be able to show that was their tails
and micro didn't say nothing but he just
mentioned you're the comedian there's
not gonna be odd sorry whatever your
name was yeah
but anyway so the first time the decade
locals was happy bro
happy Rodriguez happy the cloud hotels
yeah yeah yeah three shows outside of
San Antonio in an empty room yeah there
was nobody there three shows and it was
in this little note type bar something
like that you know it was cool guy cool
guy face was huge I guess they must get
1,700 people to party but for comedy
there wasn't even 60 I think it was
happy Rodriguez I think happy the clown
Rodriguez yep yep yeah so this is the
guy with a full cloud maker bro hosted a
show or they do it like and and then
doing these um
1970 Latino clown jokes yeah yeah we
were talking about that on the green
room me and Eric about how making the
transition from English comedy Spanglish
just straight Spanish come because my
wife was saying that it's a different
cadence and in Spanish or on Mexican TV
and it is a lot of pratfalls and
slapstick and yeah but I think that I
think they'll get it now I think we just
translated you know it's not like day
like there's so much from a different
planet or something like that but
everything's a little bit more mixed now
you know we had arrow Spears last week
yeah and then I heard that and I don't
know well we brought up the river
remember the the top 50 Latino lives
yeah who's on it oh my god dude look the
top ten are the same top tip people who
are working are cities I'm gonna do that
dude and everybody put in the mix but
the list said by talent scouts all over
the country yeah
pose you know community to get this top
50 comedian and then our do 49 by the
way and our reality is a group of like
maybe 30 people for the people that
would do drinks yeah Trevor dealer said
he was here and you what are the people
that get through names Wow
yeah I and now like what Tim magazine
always throw it out but it's so funny
because they don't even give us a round
number like the top seven you know like
and some of them aren't even comedians
it was actors yeah but I think maybe
they put that gap for [ __ ] you though
office in there yeah I'm like you Stu
doesn't even do stand-up was I own there
I remember Joe Medina was number 13 I've
ever heard eg with our little is bro oh
he says that's messed up I gotta get a
list bro but he was it was edited cuz I
said I used to see it because that's
when you know in like 2001 yeah he was
like it was also like [ __ ] number like
42 or something like that but then they
added him and it shifted a little you
could tell they took a couple people on
yeah whatever we get down I say about
early G bro uh-huh you gave that full a
line man he was [ __ ] talking like a
that's when Bart we invented by at the
morning mark that's right you me martin
moreno armando co-ceo we were on a
[ __ ] web to do a show and sucked up
idea and baking school are shy was for
the the Milosh brothers yeah yeah out
productions like wow that's the only
time i think it killed you know the
first time you realize kind of Solberg
yeah I remember that buddy it was all
loaded crazy yeah but these guys man and
after I watched the movie training day
I'm never gonna party with cholos like
that up in the bathtub with a shotgun
pointed at me but these dudes were crazy
you don't know how to party you don't
know how to drink gay you don't know
pretty come to my house a after the
after the show we'll go hang out at my
house see it's like 3:00 in the morning
I don't go with you guys man enough
Onion field out here somewhere
remember that show we did in El Paso and
at big ole [ __ ] Joe who was the manager
of the club comic strip yeah the comic
strip so we went to the other Club
Papa's and Papas and no Papa Papa
karaoke okay with the cigars yeah and
that big ol engine do Louis trauma for
you yeah Indian okay we used to have a I
don't know feels that the kitchen
manager or assistant manager something
like that big old tall to India look
crazy man look a patio ah they're crazy
you like the club man I said yes cool
yeah yeah it's cool it's cool he said
you really like I said yeah yeah well
you know what there's another club right
down the street
let's go yeah
when I mentioned you were living in
Burbank know what Hollywood City North
Hollywood off of his be and we were the
first cats to get in there you were two
to help Jack with this haha remember
though that's right yeah [ __ ] Jack
that was just pull tables there yeah I
can reopen it was a haha cafe raha ha ha
now this one's doing comedy too right
yeah but we were there for the beginning
around the beginning of a lot of things
you know it was to a restaurant right
yeah and his wife used to run it yeah I
love Jack cool guy you still go there no
I've been there in a long time no he's
got a spot in your building yeah yeah
the whole place has changed we recognize
it yeah yeah top 50 Latinos I know you
when I met you you were dating when I
started hanging out with you or seeing
you more you had a Chinese girlfriend
yeah I'm not gonna mention her name
killed me one time bro I was I was out
like back to what I do new honest I
wasn't even a pothead or drink lucky dog
just chop a little [ __ ] on our [ __ ]
on laughing really I was high this
Chinese girl bro beautiful bro like
Crouching Tiger beautiful broil and it's
gonna be in a movie this was said what
happened bro hey we went to her house
with check for Christmas II and after we
opened up a [ __ ] what Chinese boom it
took four hours and then they broke up
the karaoke my Chinese be serious
serious Chinese food Chinese movies and
karaoke bands like wow yeah
remember she dumped me yeah and then we
went up to he got job and we were doing
a show with him and that Luke Torres he
was now bro you'll forget about her a
new Toria - you'll forget I'm gonna get
[ __ ] up he walking with a beer we want
you to run into a Chinese man yeah
all the dragons the dragons were
laughing at you for a longer time ah
yeah so don't you bring a brother around
yeah Martin oops right you haven't given
any last names yeah how'd you beat it
room yeah I was there for a shoot with
both what's the name bro well they're
running the mail center and other things
that I can't mention okay now say what
was she doing it I don't think the
statute of limitations for a long time
are your own accounting we have all the
ways back to him in a tactical selfie of
my mangina yeah and you gave me two of
the guys in the warehouse yeah you're
not supposed to be sending pornography
through the mail bro I did you still got
a dry so we got people there of every
persuasion right so I open up the letter
and I look to see what it is in this
Byron so I handed it to my co-workers
and they're like oh yeah I just showed
me a dick pic okay how did you send that
to the Indian guy down in El Paso oh now
he's the same he was talking to his wife
you're by the way my wife women ever my
whole life Trey lover with all my heart
deacon in the church what'd you talk
about
oh yeah so she dumped me let's get back
to this really quick you know because
Felipa likes this one too and she dumped
me and I don't know what it is about a
woman but they'd like to come back and
torture you after they dumped you you
know saying so she comes back to the
apartment kind of like about maybe two
weeks later and knocks on the door and I
open up the door and there she is
you know she's dressed I'll fine you
know and everything like that the first
thing that comes out of her mouth is
oh well how do I look right and the
first night came out of my mouth was
like the slit that left me and that
closed the door broke actually I didn't
use the word [ __ ] but I'm a reformed man
now so you guys had a kid before the
back when she came along but I had a cat
named he calls badass cow yeah Nico
Dubrow you gather bothered to go back
flip yeah Brigid I backed it in from a
place out there and Woodland Hills are
some like that see so Nico was first and
then she came along so yeah but Nico is
cool man bro tell about that what time
you're at Willie Barcena house
me you and Martine you are [ __ ] up and
then Willie Barcena brought up that
[ __ ]
leg stretching machine and I cracked my
head open talk about the leg stretching
machine dog and never the middle of
sweet all [ __ ] up stretch it your
[ __ ] leg to the minute to the limit
to see who has a who can open the laser
lock you start think about that you know
what I love you don't grown man
I don't know move in from the past but I
love that every time Philippe it brings
up a story there's a look on Ruby's face
I don't do that hello
I mean really have have what did you
meet a bro
I love relationship ace right there t qs
tequila tequila Atlantic yeah I let it
get Pomona right exactly so yeah Willie
brought Chris Tucker there yeah yep
that's tough man all these rooms were
tough a lot of people think that oh I'm
just gonna get up and I'm gonna tell
some jokes right you gotta put a touch
either a matter of the crowd first yeah
yep and you gotta be tough man you
cannot I got the safe comedy room
that's impaired your building I'm doing
like that I'm trying to start a YouTube
page right called penalty toxin pretty
much I want to talk the the crap that I
want to talk because I got so much
if anybody knows I have like anger
issues I used to have anger issues and
you know cuz like some people get
triggered nowadays if they see like a
mug I had to get all triggered
Filipa we'll just have to say one named
Ernie G you guys love your any love you
Sebastian
Joey Medina no yeah yes yeah so you know
I never kept my mouth shut
yeah especially when I drank you know I
know brother but let's get back to that
stretching machine though so will he had
this to UFC he was or what makes more
cuz I know his kids hey shut up do it
good kitchen when his wife was in the
kitchen like we're gonna try to pick up
on her no man I don't trust you bro oh
she's by herself but she was nice Maria
was that her name join here and his
first girlfriend yeah I never met her
you talked about he got broke liver room
no no
Nicola broke I hated that phone book the
phone book of people that he will call
when he was drunk like it was
yeah I didn't have a phone stop okay so
I don't know it Willie's put a bed out
there so I can stretch my than you can
and it's east to west and back in a day
just for the fun of it oh yeah after
they took that we are they put the
[ __ ] will be [ __ ] away do a
somersault
roarsome it back my head
yeah Adam I look like Gorbachev you're
right you are the original MTV that
jackass yeah the original hell Steve
don't have a drink oh you should drink a
lot dog like a lot like black did coke
too right back down yeah but I didn't
know that you did that too later on but
who ratted me out yeah was around
everybody have you crazy blow you into a
passel you convinced a waitress to leave
right I'll pass what aboot to our lady
you had a way with the ladies right cuz
it you like didn't judge Joey Medina had
lady and then this fool said or he or
vice versa right only fat on you is so
and so Joey thing on yes crazy never I
got his teeth fix bro you did it
shut up Marilyn Martinez she used to
work in a dental office and I had
insurance and joy needed his teeth fixed
right and I love you Joey you know I
love you man here we go
so I'll it wasn't I drunk at right
anyway so anyway I told Marilyn here
when she just you know get Joy's teeth
fixed up with my my insurance system
yeah so he got his teeth fix and stuff
like that I was like about three weeks
later hey but let me throw this
disclaimer out there everybody back then
was a dog right now the Angels know I
mean it's nightclub rights comedy rights
what it is you know so you know you
leave your woman unattended for five
minutes she's fair game
well okay with that no yeah my daughter
is born because of Ruben you get the
club in San Diego Athena or the fair
game boy you have a woman that can hold
her own shall say no exactly if that's
your lady yeah okay
we did a show in San Diego
and gasoline all right I did I went to
the closer and B yes sir yeah that's his
show we did we went to the club those
one I saw oh yeah I want that one but
she was tough he was hard okay when we
crack this cold so I was to a couple
drinks okay she got comfortable she's
smile oh yes it's on
so I thought what about them watch my
hand I come back he's grinding on it so
ever dinner right
no oh go Tana grinding on you owe me
some drink small boy so anyway okay when
after that I met my baby's mom after cuz
I like you owe me some drinks and I what
am I gonna do now so I seen this girl by
herself for that one talk to her and my
daughter's history after that but so he
it was a good thing he was grinding on
the other girl you want to go what he
meant by grinding was that we're slow
dancing morning back to Joe a game where
game so a long story short I paid for
his teeth to get fixed
I leave my the Chinese girl leave her
alone for just a few minutes because I'm
up on stage
alright alright so she's in the green
room and stuff like that and I come back
enjoys all up in her face you know
trying to get with her and kiss her and
stuff like that and I'm thinking man
ain't this ibadah
you know here I do fix this dudes Here I
am fixing this dude's teeth and now he's
just trying to kiss her with the same
teeth that I figure this Brewer joins
either to her oh the only fat on you is
Ruben
the only fair on you is Reuben Quintana
see back as it was back now what did you
do that
comedian will just put up a stay put
while that's today's day but they posted
up our Facebook page [ __ ] I'm trying to
sue you dog back you used to just make a
joke about it yeah you know yeah but
Joey knows I love him
Alex knows I love my mundo I removed oh
yeah remember yeah what's his name dude
the big toe Texas dude he was in robot
genus prabhu Martinez he was funny and
Dante I remember does not take cars I'll
take cars I hit backed away
did he really yeah he passed away what
do you die I don't know you died maybe
like five years ago a big dollop died
too
yeah yeah and then like Marilyn Pass and
Freddie and all them dudes man you're
the party animal would you become a
party animal
when after my first beer yeah yeah I
couldn't control it alcoholism runs in
my family sure but I never could you
were crazy dog I had my first beer or
whatever I get regressive chuckle told
me that uh you got work whatever but
there was a drive-through and [ __ ] you
would date me with you know some crazy
ass change they were already food and
gave her those bags but in the back of
the front see the backseat
kevro's in frenzy that would share a
long as our bro oh because of Gabriel no
you said you know going added while they
were already food yeah as a
drive-through yeah he was a baby your
big dude the world is a way around here
he goes give us all your food yeah I'll
let you have two big bags what are you
guys gonna want after this yeah he's in
so much trouble when you get home bro
wait what a pain well there's more like
this is your life I think she knew I
wasn't a saint she just never
that sound of crazy man but you slowed
down right yeah I got married your
pastor no no no not yet
maybe we'll see [ __ ] man we're getting
back to work a local here with myself me
Rubick Edina and Franklin and Frank
Manzano Frank Misano isn't that cubicle
a comedian wasn't named with blonde hair
older comedian you think around with him
bro Oh Fred Fred she's a big girl
yeah so forget it back to booking kay
look was right I took Raju park Wow how
about you know I booked these three
comedians he goes and we'll share the
same hotel room you know these three
comedians will do the show fly back to
our Leigh will keep the room they'll
clean it and then buy and then uh
Franchi rubric is come up we showed us a
room yeah so we checked in they were
leaving in a Cleveland rule getting
clean so I set that out bro and then a
guy everybody that's how I might work to
do to get everybody that I wanted to
show
but it was funny about Ricky that I had
this potpourri bag bro remember we're in
New York no no no no yeah no Frenchy
some picture let your first time in New
York first time first time best time
yeah yeah Rockefeller Center and it was
wintertime too yeah everything was like
snow I just told him to bring a jacket
yeah it was fun it was fun it was a good
car mate yeah
Andrew Salazar I met him he was talking
to a number he stopped eating with us
with joy Coco - who's there - at the
Chinese place after we yeah cherry
restaurant yeah I almost have photos of
that of that place I'll answer you at
night we hung out with a comic in New
York that one time and then whatever I
have fought over voice breaking or
something I haven't fallen at home I
love rum and I remember that se but
everyone loved stuff okay hey didn't you
have a picture with I think was you on
the airplane we did a show the day after
Thanksgiving on a Friday in parking of
MIT rubric it done a book to show it
will look Torres myself and him and on
the way back home we're flying from
Boston to Los Angeles same flight the
hijackers - same one
yes a boy I think it might have been the
same plane - the same flight but there
was only like 12 people the plane and we
took a photo and rubra katana has a he
has a [ __ ] a white pillow over his
face covering up a face I mean he might
read like Arab terrorists yeah so you
know the little blue pillar right so
they put that over my head through the
pillow and then it said these guys took
no mine was the white sheet and then
these guys took the black ones and
wrapped it around their head like a
burka or hijab yeah and they were both
like like choking me at the same time
holding me and the stewardess took the
picture yeah and how long was it after
that that they did that really
like within six months let that happen
yeah yeah still didn't get paid for that
show yeah madam hooding it I don't even
know he had kids bro yeah we will we
went to the [ __ ] we wear for a check
and child support took all the whole day
in Riverside well Riverside reached out
to Boston and they try to help good a
sweet gig in my team no I have no idea
this wasn't what's the name of that
before Facebook why space so try we get
out there and then they tried to give me
the check the night before but I knew we
were gonna be drinking and I was gonna
lose it I'm on oh I just pick it up in
the morning yeah
so now in order for me to get it the
last thing I heard which was long time
ago was like okay well you need to have
the other two committee and sign off
that they took it for you together so
that they can you know but getting all
these guys was just impossible so oh
chalk it up to experience this dude I
wasn't even a party animal there but hey
man look Tory's had the [ __ ] time of
their lives
yeah and in Harvard I know they were at
Harvard brother by Cambridge bro I mean
these floors the bricks are like a
torrent over 300 years old they [ __ ]
took a brick out of the where where
power real rad in Harvard Square why
we're square he [ __ ] rip he'll try to
catch a cab holding a brick why you over
the cold case man this guy's walking us
through the the host the guy who's our
chaperone in these halls oh yeah and
then we started rousting with the mama
you didn't care then you guys [ __ ] up
you got to the door to how high they
were jumping you fell two stories yeah
yeah yeah into some bushes we jumped off
this right Harvard cuz there's some
Gators on the bunny ledge into the
bushes like you're doing a movie
yeah straight out of masters in this
matter yeah so we're in Harvard Square
and we needed to get a cab all the way
back because the the subway only ran one
way in and they stopped out after a
certain time so it was Luke that took
the brick out of it all ooh
yeah and we're waving down a cab and
they would stop and then they take off
speeding then another cab would come and
they look at us and then they speed and
then by the third time I looked over and
I see that Luke had a big old brick in
his animal who's gonna stop who's gonna
stop with you somebody's leaving you in
town and they got a big old brick in
there do you have the breaker does he
have the break I lost it yeah the
stepping stone yeah you know you hang it
up on your wall be like I went to
Harvard had it on my green I got the
branch at the apartment but I lost it so
Luke's funny though man he's doing right
now right yeah yeah they hooked that
whole family's talented my him and his
brother Pete I never met Pete yeah had a
rock band called the bow him yeah that's
a cool name one time like a punk rock
town we did a show it was a wedding and
I opened up for mm-hmm now that was
interesting and the people were in the
bag my darkness and not not only yeah
yeah we was a wedding uh-huh and then
what after we get ready to eat I went up
I don't know if I'll wait we're at still
a don't know what a nice la yeah and
then after that you don't want to I
don't know we went but you did it he
killed I was scared
State House no that house just me and
you oh yeah I was opening it when you're
out here you'll get anywhere just again
weirdest games you did bro if they were
okay okay my cell yeah well we got taken
up the Sacramento that one weekend and
there was nobody in the audience
remember it was me you Luke at this big
ole auditorium and Tower Theatre yeah
yeah and there was like nobody in the
audience and they still want to go
through it over routine yep we had
followed us through here - yeah and walk
daddy
up these shows no throw out a name but I
don't wanna you know hang the wrong bat
show on somebody and we did this one
show whoa crazy and central you ever do
the show out there oh yeah with yeah
yeah yeah man and yeah it would be you
and Apache the guild right and there
were security service that goes all over
the place
I left Patrick to gear but I don't like
going in gigging with them and stuff
could it be an eye doctor because I like
you know I love you Patrick but dude I
don't know how many times I've wasted
having fun just you know you needed to
go out the brine comic right black you
know book you when he said let me pen
see you with any was blind I didn't even
get a chance to go see it like the beach
or nothing like that is that to make
sure Patrick was given to our Miami stay
local Comedy Jam for micro blows oh the
tour or any raping the taping when is
this I must be the only why did you do
yeah how many kilos you do this I did
Ryder 1212 not Oliver merde
but yeah so you did so you take your
local L comedy jams I did the 12 all
together that's that's including Konig
you and then the NBC thing the and then
like the funniest funny and the Latino
la festival so out of the K locos slash
local Comedy Jam it was probably close
to like about this seven yeah Jeff
Valdez and happy and then my role is I
think Mike likes me though he's always
give me a hard time man I don't know
what it is he just didn't like me you
never get that uh I mean like you didn't
but you ever get that that he just
didn't like me at the beginning yeah but
that's my spot remember I remember they
drove by the house at the apartment your
apartment yeah who did it was Mike and
Gabriel outside you know was there I was
in the apartment and and Jeff was inside
the apartment with me in the Edwin San
Juan and and they had called me up from
the outside right a we're outside the
house and that's when
Jeff wasn't getting along with what
Gabriel and Jeff wasn't getting along
with Mike and he'd want to come out Jeff
came out Jeff came out and Edwin came
out everyone's always been like the
Peacekeeper right so then I go out there
and Gabriel and and Jeff are ready to
just you know throw down and do get a
fight yeah Yeah right there those three
the dead boy Gabriel Studio City is like
a it was like at night or they tell
orchestra food row by looking for a
rumble hit yeah yeah shut mic is 40
pected yeah yeah Studio City up lion
kill buddy Karl house all [ __ ] up and
see how both you guys yeah yeah I said
that to Mike I said that to Jeff I said
that to gay bro Edwin was off to the
side so he didn't get any other the
wrath you know I was gonna miss
everybody know if anybody came out of
the car moved the wrong way I was
bumping man I was if anybody if anybody
but I love you a couple days ago you
were just asking like did Mike not like
me right you know not me he pulled up
because Gabriel had beef with Jeff back
then I don't know if they still do so
they just wanted to see what was gonna
happen right when I was hey this ain't
gonna happen or I got mad you know if
anybody jump if anybody looked out the
window if anybody came out of the street
they were gonna get it both of those
devil dude in your house just chillin
drinking which one I had so many Devils
in my house Oh Jeff Oh Jeff yeah I was
just hanging out dude yeah him and Edwin
just hanging out and chillin and smoke
your brother you probably yeah oh yeah
of course
James to smoke weed back to they stop
yeah no more drinking no but so gave a
microbe let him [ __ ] you
Gabriel showed up or someone else
probably right now you told me this but
kath crazy huh yeah the kid they say
come out come outside
yeah and I was I was trying to hold Jeff
back but Jeff wouldn't have it any of it
you know Jeff a little back there - Wow
yeah working out now or what or is it
just a heavier one let's go Harry
Liddell okay well we all got heavy so
yeah yeah we little stick it was crazy
dude
but we're do although Jeff north the
[ __ ] back oh my god
you're the pivot people [ __ ] you got a
problem we used to take Jeff to his gigs
when you first started remember in the
home savings van yep we used to be mail
couriers and stuff and shipping and they
gave we had access to all the fleet
trucks and and gas cards and everything
you would go to our gigs dude we'd go to
the County theater after the shallots on
Melrose Melrose in the Astaire LaBrea
know I think there's a show right there
yeah I think and we used to just get all
kinds of sandwiches you know they would
sell out the story you know with gas so
yeah we feed ourselves and we take TIFF
everywhere man yeah
Riverside you know LA if they'd only let
them in to do the show cuz you know you
can't be inside the barb you would love
to what he was right right and in
Riverside what you guys doing Carl's
O'Brien's back there I know the there
was named uh monopolies are the one up
for folks ed monopolies yeah you
remember that for it was before my time
but I always heard it on the radio yeah
hopfully with a comedy club yeah
tonight's so long time ago sure we
started back in 94
Byron started me up in 89 then I got
married
so I dropped out like from 90 to 92
somewhere oh nice I'm sorry again when
you found out you broke over the woman
you got or when you open up that [ __ ]
Valentine's Day card ah which one's our
you open up are you thinking about
safeguarding to the wrong person
yeah how's me yeah yeah all right well
you know love love just ended that day
you know you open it you didn't see the
name on the envelope is it just said
babe or something like that and I open
it up and then you know and I hand it
right back to God you think at what line
did you realize it wasn't you was she
like going to the last novel ah so the
one that killed me bro was the word Zeke
I love you sir oh my god [ __ ] Zee
I never hit a Guatemala as much as much
as I did when man that chick did that to
me do that hairy Guatemala I wanted us
to invade Oh jeepers I wanted the the
jungles to Mexican Embassy we need to
evade anything that started we just
booked you to go to Guantanamo Bay no
screw that
and then her perfume I still can't stand
that perfume sunflowers more like
beggars it should be more like the charm
of the chick from Universal the little
tiny one Stephanie doing what mom yeah
they raisin the cheap never heard of
that joke why isn't there any poker in
the in the jungle because what the
mothers all jungle right why don't they
play poker in the jungle too many
cheetahs Park your podcast oh not know
podcast YouTube channel penalty talks
penalty talks your partner yeah ahmad
ali palestinian he's a muslim comedian
I'm a Christian communion I don't know
how we're making it work but we do roof
yeah that's crazy how many apples do you
have no two you doing what do you do a
matter they live yeah I just don't Matt
the house man I don't have like a big
old you know fancy studio like you guys
do yeah yeah that's cool you got
everything here but I just do it at the
house you know kind of just like you
know what the with the note 9 phone just
my style and it's got to get it out
there and got to get the first few out
there
penalty talk so you can talks at
Instagram and YouTube penalty talks yeah
and then if you go to my Instagram page
our cue comedian then you'll be able to
see the links to the to the the shows
and stuff like that on YouTube so you
know share it man when you guys get a
chance to listen to it and stuff like
that like it hate it put any comment
what do you talk about what do you you
know it's like this I have an opinion
obviously a lot of things and and then
and Byron knows behind knows that and
Felipa knows that it's trigger words
did you kill me what time bro I'm sorry
cut you off at school this fool care
debate on uh-huh I see don't debate with
other comedian Tony Sanneh who the
Republican uh-huh and this was critical
I mean face it bro
I don't give a [ __ ] bro have you ever
picked a show up did you ever run for
office who me yeah we somebody to
Samantha what's going on I could debate
compared to the stuff that was coming
out today right now on this podcast
would you run from made now yeah I had a
saying earlier you know hey my wife
knows that we're crazy she knows that
we're all crazy and stuff fact that she
doesn't know the details and manage you
just sprays you know I wouldn't say no
one I wouldn't say I just I just know
they weren't you a little askew I just
what do I say
I mean what do I say without talking
trash or I just say the truth yeah okay
I love by say Lea right it's a great
place to raise your kids get some fresh
air is there no traffic right the only
sucky part about it is there
thing closes down at eight so there's no
food afterwards and I like to eat and
y'all know that and then what else
there's no comedy scene there's only one
convent so this growing rule well yeah
this discovery didn't know there's still
no comedy scene though and there's only
one dude that's got a lockdown on the
comedy scene out there and if you're a
young comic and Fresno in madera in
Visalia and Tulare anything between San
Francisco and Los Angeles then you're
screwed because there's no way for you
to come up you know there's no open
mikes out there there's no place to
practice your craft and stuff like that
know these dudes that are out there in
the Central Valley they're killing they
come out here and they'll do whatever
they can to just come right here and get
you know five minutes at the laughs
factors and like that we were spoiled we
could go to Laugh Factory Comedy Store
improv all these little bars out here
and stuff like that like cilantro's
Daily Planet whatever tortillas right
wall goes carbon replay right right and
remember it wasn't even that dude from
The Daily Planet
Ron never Ron Ron yeah whatever happened
him I don't know
Oh didi you think oh but there's nothing
out there for comedians and there's this
one due to a promoter out there and you
know I don't know I gotta give it to him
right because he's he's he's still alive
he's still in business and stuff yeah
but he got productions but if he try and
open up your own spot out there you
can't do it he's got everything locked
down like the Fox Theater he's got a
well this is what I heard I don't know I
haven't seen the contract but this is
what I heard so like if you he has a
contract with the Fox here that if you
bring an act in 30 days before my show
30 days after then you know we're not
gonna have a contract together so then
that locks that end so right nobody else
come I can come down unless you're
somebody big like you know Carlos Mencia
or something like that or Lopez but it's
tough man it's tough out there too just
to get the stage time so if you're gonna
start comedy you know I suggest that you
leave the Central Valley you know leave
and get out into the cities where you
can actually get some work done
portable portable sex - yeah the city is
nice but there's nothing out there bro
you've been out there Porter Road up
there that one bar right not no more
Charlie's Charlie's blows they closed it
down please had comedy stand-up comedy
married right here and then left playing
each other to a hip hop's comedy party
yeah but after with all the locals but
then you go take a piss and there's
another
bro in the country yeah rules close to
Western and hip-hop and the same in the
same place they just beat everybody in
the middle you just cannot cross either
way you gotta pay wasn't monopolies like
that not the Riverside once I was and
hip-hop in this I was country yeah yeah
back in the days of the Metro or the
Cabbage Patch Metro that was the one to
Myra yeah but you [ __ ] you ever a
[ __ ] cooking show now right chopping
it up with a bow link Boykin breaking
this boy in watch on youtube.com Boykin
brothers I mean yeah he went to public
school guys glasses don't look delicious
pumpkin cheesecake oh yeah man you're
gonna like that so you never come in I'm
sorry what did you start cooking man
well there's a long story play music and
after my baby's mama got pregnant I not
thanks to me oh yeah thanks Ruben yeah I
retire from comedy and then went into
cooking brought over what time man you
told me ain't gabriel iglesias like a
prett lady so tell you you get you just
stay so prolific [ __ ] to us thank you
that you told him what time man wasn't
your day like a man sometimes man that
they [ __ ] you up thought about it
brother yeah I guess it's true I've done
that now well yeah any time after that
yeah you know sometimes oldest I hold
aside like six more serious but I never
lets anything get to a man say ever
since I known him everything would piss
me on Bello ha
everything would trigger me he's like
Vulcan Roy he's got no feelings you
grind up on his girl and he went and I
wish people would learn that I wish I
could get Americans out of you know
black they don't care they don't care
about the bills they don't show up with
another comedian brought to another
comedian I was trying to get a comedian
out of the house right right so it's
just kind of like you know he's got that
talent about him he's just
no emotion you know I think I just found
your vice president right hey you
showing up with a shovel mr. triggered
and no emotion you showed up with a
shovel he showed up with Deskins right
hey we love you Tony Sanchez so why'd
you have a meltdown Byron I didn't want
kids I love my baby to death but at the
tide of what kids matter of fact I mean
listening but I did work at least not at
that time at that time
yeah and when I had the kid I didn't
know what to do go this way that way
[ __ ] ask me already by that time had to
Philippa says a blue you know how they
did they had that commercial where you
got to give 50 cents to these these kids
that don't eat and stuff yeah do they
ever send you back pictures of your own
kids we had an estranged relationship my
ex-wife and I you know and the kids it
happens it happens here the job you one
time who barely her family no no she did
oh she's done she's defended myself I
defend see there's a way it was a fight
the fighting couple everybody see the
public yeah see there's a way that you
can defend yourself by deflecting and
not like hitting I would deflect that
was a joke I was like matrix deflecting
right man she was trying to land some
bombs on you're just like you know
scratching yeah that's all it took Oh
handsome long hair and funny you know
you're happy with the hardcore latina
yeah yes it's over baby the penis so he
betrayed me say I gotta take a ride okay
you drive myself all the way from hours
later we're in Riverside a while here
can you check this and give it to my ex
okay what is it
divorce papers okay almost a year
McDonald's you go dear and she was
getting served over there and so I went
in there that say hey you know what we
cool but we were told me to give you
this what is it oh she's just crying at
you and she's done hug and then the
black now one aruba's kids a little dog
you know I I would have a habit of
picking crazy crazy chicks crazy girls
the girl that that came up from El Paso
it was my mom dude her mom says the
waitress right yeah her mom said you
know she's just our Jade she just died
dude no way yeah she's or the mom yeah
the girl the girl she died what last
year sometimes huh huh a year and half
ago for being too drunk and then I guess
what
viral says that she just chokes to death
or something like that yeah because she
was too you know like two drunken
Iranian god oh yeah me and her contact
each other
yeah we're cool anyway she worked at
though you surely right yeah yeah yeah I
met connected to Facebook and we were
talking and then a week later she was
dead yeah so her mom said take care of
her she's doing too much coke she's
drinking too much she's partying too
much you know can you do something so I
brought her out to LA with me and and
she stopped the coke after a while but
she's got into just a pot and that's it
pot and drinking it and then we just
went our separate ways are you were the
intervention program
I took a lot of crap she was we're at
this one bar called gold where I put my
cold fingers Goldfinger's is a little
cool little bar right there and North in
Hollywood man off of Highland or
something like that I think it's
Highland or Franklin and as there's no
room to move man everybody's dressed mod
like 60 Styles so cool the music was bad
news like jazz
yeah that was cool man and Joey Medina's
back up against the wall like this and I
like his hands up against the wall with
the back against the wall Nikki know
what's going on with the man is he just
making room now she's all like grabbing
on and everything and Joe is looking
like April what do I do like a vice
grips so you know I had to deal with
that all the time everywhere I went she
was just grabbing on dudes and just like
and I'm thinking if it wasn't for a mom
this chick would have been kicked out a
long time ago when she was sober she was
cool you know she was mr. Brady
but when yeah yeah so finally I kicked
her out
drew and I we went to buy wheat one time
and a regular drug dealers Bollywood and
she was there bro hitting the bong and I
said oh you buy weed here now yeah and
she was my boyfriend yeah what's the
Arab and I know really big huh we give a
big hug then that do got stuff car
cheese the other dude was from Boston
the friend he has speaking up for
another friend that was all quiet and
little and he's not shy bro that do a
shine and he's all so what do you mean
Philippe you've been at or to use the
mobster life after a show right yeah
long story short and we're back are like
a month later the food we're all sad
what happened bro she took everything
but you know how every one of those
situations where I could have told the
dude to watch out I could have told them
everything but the way they acted with
me I feel you know what you never
believed it if I tell with you Brian
yeah in that fool is all I will rule
like a hater
Jewellery if you would have told me I
want to believe you I was a guy that she
was with he was all I could love and in
that like I mean I was in lovin but I
knew what I had you know and he didn't
know he was in here I was doing it for
the mom and that's what that's what
makes the Mexican moms on guilt you into
doing stuff man but yeah he had no idea
he wasn't hip like you dog her mom was
crazier yeah I used to do cleansing is
on the house at night with the sage and
then the web she used to hide the
butcher knives because her aunt was nuts
get so you saw the genetic crazy and you
still you know I felt bad you're the
real hero
[Laughter]
the cookie shows chopping it up with the
Boykin brothers as me and my younger
brother and you know Boykins we're
Boykins that's my original when keith is
my middle name
although that Byron Keith you know
there's another
there was a can we say merica over there
and his name was Byron Marty kaan he had
such a flaming reputation man and they
only always thought it was a noise oh no
it's the other barn Yahoo Don jr. he hit
on ya and they thought it was me yeah
took jr. in the gabion that time in the
closet yeah jr. was gay too
but we love you Junior I still talk to
jr. you do yeah
love you Junior remember remember you
got accosted Junior we're dividing you
here it wasn't me it wasn't me
well yeah so fire started fondling him
and not me and then at me know later on
junior was like explaining it you know
dude dude why did you just stop on
Manny's oh I didn't want to offend him
you have been kidnapped by bar Santa oh
yeah Wow bro let's go right yeah in his
defense he keeps pretty good teacher in
when I'm sober like okay yes yeah but
other study tells you to do he will do
it that's right I did know like dog he
got tired of the way I talk one time big
time right bro so will you talk bro the
wave song like that to all that bass bro
I miss beaurevel
bro you stole the dog and we gave it a
bunch of paper put all these people here
Marlboro let's talk like that for every
day bro so you get to the stage yeah we
got to talk about that one time about
you and he said he did that to you he is
always
the way these fools talked as his
flavors and torturous you know dad who
just didn't like you growing up or walk
on fire dog doesn't make you better
comic okay working brothers chopping up
with so you went to culinary school I
did Cordon Bleu
yes cordon bleu and that was the
toughest a year and a half if you were
blood huh your hell breezy so I went to
cordon bleu and it's after the daughter
was born yes
okay that was part of my rehab finger
thing yeah finger things out right
[Laughter]
anyway cordon bleu to start working in
different restaurant things like that
got my chops up and then I still want to
do comedy I tried to work it in but I
couldn't do both a conference and so the
comedy was suffering because I was so
focused on cooking after that I just
gave it up
I came up comedy and you start focusing
on cooking anyway years later my brother
and I we were gonna have a my nephew do
a YouTube channel he's a fireman and we
found out that oh well like a hundred
thousand applicants try every year but
they can't pass the physicals my nephew
he's buff and being strong like that and
we're gonna have him show people how to
do how to pass the physicals and we
thought was brilliant so when time come
to shoot he got scared I can't do that I
don't do it like we got a production
we're gonna do
let's just do it ourselves you know
funny together and low comedy with the
food and we have a good rapport and we
just started to jump and it grew from
there so so what's your specialty is it
desserts is it I like to actually the
Mexican food I love to cook makes me but
our channel we cook everything
and when our niche is making it fast
easy and simple for the average person I
have some chef friends who like get
pissed off because it's not authentic
and it's not from scratching their the
longer you make it takes like five star
yeah right you just you've got a box of
something and put it together make it
yeah and then for a while there you were
doing the ratings like he would go out
and do oh you're a critiques inside like
that yeah yeah so he's got a cool he's
got a cool website Mila food right okay
yeah YouTube channel yeah you follow
them right at Boykin brothers on Twitter
Pinterest Instagram Facebook and they
thought might be still my wife yes now
and even though he will not be email
there man for some advice and Boykin
brothers B or Y ki n beat our OS and
gmail.com yeah you know show coming up
hold on so what time we got how much
more time we got we got some time well
let me ask you I want to ask you yeah hi
everybody burns out man pyro yeah man
thanks pick up my number homeboy oh you
owe me if you need some more yeah I'll
hook it up all right
oh yeah and I'll tell Jose well I'm good
but but this boy can we don't want the
we don't want that's what he said I
highly doubt it
Oh black man in here they're gonna
Photoshop you bro the other guy like the
old spice man put them on a horse I hate
you
cool - cool thank you brother man doggie
you're responsible for the daughter and
this cookie channel yeah cuz when I
started Reuben Quintana a long time I
ever worked with you well on that big
movie look so every story would have
little big Liam Barrett hey Byron before
you go Byron you know bar is a manly man
had women and stuff like that and and
remember that one time we pulled up to
the Shell station and you went out to go
get to your little box of gym hats so
Byron goes out and and he pulls up into
the South Station his favorite child
station that he used to go to before he
would go and and by his prophylactics
right yeah yeah and Byron says he would
always buy the the magnum version yeah
cuz you know I don't know if it's true
or not but you know he did that for
himself but anyway long story short I
don't know what the cops - remember that
story Oh so Byron pulls up in front cuz
it's a Shell station where they just put
out the little metal basket because they
don't want nobody robbing them and stuff
like that so so Byron's pointing at the
at the condoms that he wants and then
the guy looks out into the car cuz I'm
in the passenger seat cuz he wants to
see what fine chick Byron has right and
he sees me in the car and he looks at
Barney's I know no it's not like that
guys I know it's okay it's okay Bruce I
don't judge Mr barkis is it another time
these two share the detectives le a PD
detectives came to his house and they're
looking for his on and and Byron opens
up the doors oh yeah and Byron's like in
a towel you just got a towel around your
waist i lookin on my ankle came in and
talked to me and then down wet cuz i
have a shower and i come down my hairs
all wet cuz I never used to dry my hair
with the hair dryer my sister used to
hate me for that right because my hair
was beautiful bras like it was straight
no split ends just no product in it man
just let it naturally dry those gorgeous
he looks at me because I'm coming down
the stairs with my hair I'm a hollow
hanging out to the side and another time
they pull us over
Ruben environ stories we can go all day
with this and the sheriff's where one of
them was a rookie you know instead LAPD
right no le shares and we were coming
back from the movies and we saw a lethal
weapon and so they pull us over and they
get us out of the car and then the guy
said who's the trainer he says do you
know why we pulled you over and I'm here
we go again right and the lady says yeah
what were you guys coming from and I
said well we saw we just got them seeing
lethal weapon oh yeah well I got the
same kind of gun and she's all shaking
like Barney Fife you know reaching for
her gun and stuff man I said man I wish
you - and the guy said that the copies
are like no do you really want to know
why we pulled you over because you guys
fit the description of two people that
just robbed the liquor store you know
that's a mole and they give you all the
time I wish I wish you would arrest
these two people you know and that guy's
all why cuz we're always getting pulled
over for the crap that they do you know
I didn't know what to say you know yeah
good oh dear well fool were some foodies
coming up no actually I'm working on the
YouTube channel right now so I got some
corporate stuff coming up but that's not
all
yeah yeah so Ryan I do corporate I do
churches you know things like that high
schools and jute and middle schools or
junior High's is what they call them so
you do mean [ __ ] now yeah for the most
part I would have cuss words and stuff
like that but I wouldn't get raunchy you
know yeah so but you guys know that was
so boo the bet Ambria tour is coming to
your town if you I want I'm ready to go
away free tickets but check this out
that's tough you guys ever heard of Flat
Stanley you get it at school and you
take the little Flat Stanley everywhere
and take pictures yeah but no flat
Felipe put it off and you post a
different place in man you could color
it and do different things like a see he
sitting next to
Donna that's a folder right there it
will agree whoa he's everywhere I'll
have to make sure the crib and just
mention your city and the most creative
ones I'll give you a pair of free
tickets like if you live in Austin Texas
and then you have this all over Austin
yeah if I like it I'll give you free
ticket to the show if you live like in
Stockton and you have this anywhere the
bad ambulatory is just cut it off put it
up on stage or whatever you're at hang
out with him take him to a strip bar
take him to school take up for breakfast
take a photo of it tag me and just tag
flat Felipe and I hook you up
print it out and link it to Instagram
design the color cut it out take it to
all your adventures take photos post it
with the hashtag flat Felipe and mention
your city and we'll choose the most
creative one and you win free tickets
that's it
and also man I'm gonna be at Irvine
California this weekend Salinas
California May 31st fox dealer Stockton
California June 1st Bob Hope Santa
Barbara June 7th gonna Theatre Austin
Texas June 8th month moody the Moody
Theater in Austin Texas and also San
Jose New Orleans NYC Atlanta was so cool
she could stop by to one of our shows
one day give you a do a spot with us
okay yeah we're gonna like you bro they
like your stories yeah crazy yeah I
don't know I don't know half of this
stuff and I only remember half I'll be
doing good I'm gonna be googling a lot
of names by a handsome store we had some
cats that were hilarious man like Raul
Martinez Marilyn robe artistas was a
Vietnam vet yeah he will have jokes
about him being Latino and then being a
being out being a war veteran from the
Vietnam War he'd have a joke at this he
goes he was sailing down something about
I'm his wife or something [ __ ] with me
by wearing like show come to dress all
sexy with black pajamas
you know or whatever I woke up sweaty
what happened did I have another
nightmare he goes yeah what did I do
you sent me for more ammunition is it a
natural thing for comedians to to make
fun of their old ladies or what putting
in the routine I think you write what
you know
yeah yeah we all know that yeah
your cover is clean right most part like
like rebirth he didn't even try to be
cleaner just the way it comes out not
100% clean
I still touch on the topics you know if
I got to talk about drugs relationship
sex or whatever buddy is clean I would
people say all people retouched it early
have it bro
let this generation what you mean that
when they say oh man you can be Puerto
Rico to over Porto Rican stop bro that's
his version of it dawg
yeah have you heard this version yet no
bro this plays all hip-hop for the
weekend but also Puerto Ricans brothers
are not hip-hop they're regular foods
like not Mexicans or cholos am i right
Eric right right yeah now you know see
every running around beating up people
at the Puerto Rican parade now you see
how [ __ ] all fools and secret admirer
in LA the money will you go Eric the
nationality that's probably not ah thank
you got a Q Bar this is all my yeah yeah
I like I moved out here somewhere is he
from New York for like he's saying I got
in I grew up in the suburbs yeah Latino
lights like I don't think Eli's tequila
light right here yeah like I did a show
in New York I remember I was at the
Nuyorican poets cafe it was a big Porto
Rican Day is for the Puerto Rican Day
Parade
well 15 things first of the month yeah
it's like the fifth and they have be on
a lineup and the crowd did not like me
they were just like yeah it's not that
this is not the guy I didn't have that I
didn't have the skinny goatee or the
shades on tonight they were all mine
beer yeah they were not they were not
fans of mine you know the Beast truth
all the lights I didn't have to beat it
I didn't have to beated Porto Rican flag
around my neck they were not happy
hey comedies I don't know how do you
guys feel about comedy nowadays as
opposed to like when we were coming
through how we could talk about
everybody everything talked about blacks
Asians
whites Latinos Native Americans just get
out there and roast each other I mean
just totally roast each other and now if
you get out there and you say a joke
anything remotely close to that do you
think that that it's it's changed yeah
my leg like it like there's some jolt
I'm pretty sure like if I'm like like
with joy medina would say the Latino
spelling contest then he won't be
looking spreecast
yeah and write on the wall a lot of
people might get that offensive like hey
we're not all like that it I started
seeing that back when we were doing the
college's like back when we went to a to
Boston MIT and stuff like that there are
stuff out there that the people weren't
laughing at and but it's stuff that's
true it's real it's like this is where I
grew up in a house you know with no
lights sometimes no money for food
alcoholism you know go down the street
there's you know there's gang trouble
you know that's just the way it is and
and you go to these colleges at least
back then and I was like in the early
90s and stuff people would like not
wanna identify with them yeah it's just
kind of like it's still like that what
color could bathe a kid 18 they don't
know they've never been a comic so they
don't know what that is they don't know
oh we could say messed up things we
could talk about this stuff that happen
in your life like growing up or like
alcoholism and stuff so for them it's
like oh no we don't we don't do it
because they they don't know any better
I've done colleges where it's been bad
and then as the kids aged I don't know
when you came to my school I didn't I
get it now okay and you're like oh you
just need enough that life experience
yeah I don't college you where I thought
that more about my path and then I hear
like oh yeah they feel bad for you like
ah I grew up with a drunk there Oh
laughing but then before that oh my yeah
yeah that's horrible
right right so they don't know where the
laugh for the thing is there's a lot of
the people that do have those
experiences and they're in a big-ass
auditorium with people that have it they
don't they just [ __ ] go with the
conformity because they don't want to be
all like [ __ ] yeah it's kind of like to
go with the floors [ __ ] sheep it's
like a you remember Danny Mora right
yeah they're more oh he told me that if
you write your jokes and you you make
sure that you cater to the women that
you make the women laugh then the guys
are going to
because if you make the guys laugh first
and it's offensive like to a woman then
she's not gonna laugh and then he's not
gonna laugh because that's his date then
it's gonna make for ugly evening for
everybody so what you gotta do is make
sure that the women are okay with the
joke first then the guys will come on
board so yeah that's too much things
about it I remember I did a short
Chicago and there was a college class
they were to my show they were offended
all my jokes they got a catalogue or
whatever school catalog or some other
school down the street by the theater
right but guess what class went to my my
kids what class they were taking
diversity as in the team okay yeah
how the [ __ ] that occurred in college
now oh that's so they were to my show to
get them a little diversity in a little
no I didn't get that so let me tell you
man they're some of them walked out some
of them hated me some of them liked me
but the one who did really liked me
she wrote me these long letters like
this you know words I didn't read it my
wife read it wrote it she broke it down
to me basically she told me that they
were gonna talk about me at the next
class and break down my comedy and all
that stuff good but I wanted to have
something to back you up with you know
when they talk about you I want to have
something to say and I thought if I were
to read that little [ __ ] just say leave
it as that right but not Lisa throwing
where I was born
what kind of hardships I cooked through
cause you gave a feeling of where it
come from cuz there are no comedy matter
the ethic now the information but you
have to have a Richard Pryor you know
like why he hates white through these
jokes like this you know I see the
Edward so much right right
you Tommy tell me one time I love that
you have her in your life because comics
right away go [ __ ] get back up I
thought it like what she's like no no
let me let me she doesn't translation I
was like yeah I'm gonna translate [ __ ]
hold on
so our up hardship yes you all did all
this [ __ ] that we've been study before
and then I don't thinking like the
blouse crazy like somebody who knows
good to be learned
diversity sensitivity yeah and you sent
her to a comedy show you know there's
you all over
versity just cool look don't look for
your comedy shows don't look for it go
look for it in the network saying that
were the world that will you need your
diversity and yes the NBC yeah but they
don't go look for the turn goes small
now I look for us they I'm not even
gonna I'm not even part of the
University bro
so anyways I didn't go to college but
now I'm part of the College requirement
oh yeah part of the college required me
like you had to go to my show if you
were a path to class next week I'll be
taking Felipe 101 people follow you are
cute comedian Instagram Facebook and was
the other on Twitter are you talking
high schools yeah talk about anybody
want to book you from this show to talk
to the school oriented yeah I got a
prison to rip off your testimony I
wanted I'm one of the only comedians
that's ever been in the Folsom before
some prison so I was there about five
years I think Gilbert went one time yeah
I remember Gilbert has a story he could
say it because from the gist of it they
him and some dude who was a singer
forgot the brother's name is talented to
jail but who Jayla but no no no another
dude is a if I remember his name I'll
drop it right now but they walked him to
the the cellblock and then they let him
in there and then the the team the the
staff that was there to watch him or the
guards took off and they left Gilbert
and that dude in there alone for like a
long time and they didn't know where
what to do they pulled it out you know
they got funny and they told the jokes
and the other dude I think was a singer
and stuff like that so no scary
experience yeah but he pulled it through
but see that's when your old-school man
you know what to do you you just it just
comes out of you you know the the the
the natural funding is the comedy
because we grew up in a time where we
had to go to places like tortillas and
they would boo you they would throw
things at you they would pull a gun on
you yeah exactly exactly and like you
had to be like real good and we broke
with a bluff right right right
you pay me a burrito attitude and 20
bucks take that yep
so the comedies changed you were talking
about the or somebody's talking about
the political correctness that's what
the penalty talks is all about because I
don't believe in this whole PC attitude
because when we were kids
everybody was fair game and that's the
way it should be and now they're
bringing back on the family and that
Jefferson's house that has to come out
yet I don't know what it's gonna do they
live like what though is it gonna be
live real the real stuff that they used
to talk about or is gonna be live PC and
they're gonna be trying to push a
message through the whole thing because
that's not comedy man you said I think
it's like they're gonna be reading an
old script and it's like Jamie Foxx
Wanda Sykes I don't know I don't know if
they don't be good yeah sure no it's a
show I don't know if yeah whoever's
playing Archie Bunker's gonna be saying
when Archie Bunker was saying all the
family was originally a British show
I wasn't they were brought to America
and they changed it to all the family so
is Three's Company
Marilyn though the British go to robin's
nest yeah there's all become days you
told me what an originality huh
yeah no folks over the house of cards it
was a Brits a hardcore British show
British Parliament Philippe I remember
you saying one time that Jackie Gleason
said never take a scalpel to comedy
remembers in that yeah yeah so yeah
that's true if it works it works right
but see that's true to some extent you
know because because some people out
there still trying the same old stuff
that they used to a long time ago and oh
I'm not gonna say name but anyway I
believe it man funny is funny too right
well I still write all the time lovest
oh you too love the Beatles days you
love you know I cannot you are not be on
stage I love being on stage
me too I can't I can't it's like it's
it's life do it I might as well I'm out
it would be six feet under if I'm not
writing for something writing for some
open about comedy club business do you
know comedy club be successful in that
area you talk about I have to do a
Leonard oh yeah
Leonard I love you Leonard but a bottle
in the car ran him over and he still
survived bro a car little around another
hit bro this guy doing shower you gonna
it we're gonna charge you you do you Bri
the breaker we're gonna pay for this for
advertisement right there's a comedy lot
for advertisement right but when you get
to the town just like you ever seen
those cut out what they call the cut-up
billboard hardboard cutouts
yeah but it's like I said the sign
barber signs right yeah they're all hung
like this a big old Budweiser sign the
theater real small and Eric's River a
real smaller but they're all over the
city that's a promotion it's like it
makes it seem a Budweiser sponsoring a
show but in that uh-huh I think old
school prom I did a show that one time
bro where bro it was like everyone in
the city did a favor bro and I pretty
sure if somebody made out of money then
normally our shoulders bartenders real
bartenders this [ __ ] hired a
barber school so part of the curriculum
was to serve beer during the comedy show
to get a a uh-huh so those free work
already right there then outside though
the Budweiser truck and a Budweiser
stand there was something beer outside
the theater before you go in front
nobody we went to buy we went to a
friend's wedding recently and everybody
in her bridal party was
oh that's the florist that guy right
there he did the decorations I was like
what so then it's kind of like he has
the fun he's a godfather of flyers past
eight that's funny
and we're gonna throw it that guy with
that does the joke with Hawaii t-shirt
or the [ __ ] price tag yeah
Georgio's yes sir Joe Google dr. Joe
showed up to my short one times man with
a escorted thing bro
it was of your hot black chick uh-huh
all right people were served food a big
hand for Reuben Quintana RQ Quintana
Instagram on Twitter
Eric Rivera thank you again for showing
up again got to have your back row three
Vittorio shows
yeah June 11th we have develop drugs in
Spanish Filipe he'll be there along with
Martin Rizzo so I'll come out like for
Center yeah June 9th I'm at the Brea
improv so come on up as a promo code
Rivera free tickets Rivera free tickets
to check out every vertebrae improv June
9th we're gonna remind you next week
again
hashtag Eric Rivera brain problem where
we katana has private shows you would
have to work for Toyota to watch if you
guys want me to do a show just hit me up
on Instagram or Facebook or you know
Twitter and stuff like that I'll let you
know what the prices are you know what's
crazy about that fool I asked Google s
um I seen in my mom what do people hate
you dog you're a big SD fan you [ __ ]
delusional just acts that way dog I
can't answer that without without
opening up another our penalty talks
yeah that body
sixty bucks I hit him up at the no he
hit a bump I was gonna pay you bro but
did my friend die bro I don't give a
[ __ ] beer I'm [ __ ] that [ __ ] it over
though buddy
did the devil follow him to Santa
Barbara do or somewhere no because make
sure it was a pie reading machine on say
what's up of the devil or Jeff he
thought that early Geodude his jokes so
that is how crazy Jeff is he drove his
car always had a Barbara and Senator
back and watch the whole act man I wanna
[ __ ] about ball what's up fool